hey everybody welcome back to park
attacks and in this part of the campaign
were getting quite a few different paths
for one we have ice shelf islands up
here we can also go to Biscayne Beach
and we could try Batavia okay and I
think I'm just gonna pick and choose
whichever I feel like doing most at any
time and today I want to get into ice
shelf islands because I think it's a
good change of pace from all of the
tropical scenarios that we have so far
and also it's the first snowy biome so
that's gonna be interesting this is
actually one of the scenarios which I
played the most before the game came out
so I do have some experience with this
but that said I didn't theme it very
well so this time I'm gonna try and go
for some kind of Scandinavian theme I'm
mostly thinking about the surroundings
of Gothenburg in Sweden and see if I can
turn this into something also something
which I should note and I haven't
pointed out so far is that the scenario
goals have been tweaked since the cane
is since the game came out so some of
the scenarios that I've played might
have actually changed the in terms of
what their objectives are so yeah lots
of stuff that even I'll be able to see
are gonna be slightly different from the
way that they were when the game just
came out just because they are balancing
it out a little bit based on feedback
that players have been giving in any
case oh god I said it again it's not too
difficult of a scenario we have a fair
amount of flat rides here
roller coasters are gonna be a bit more
tough since we don't have anything yet
or no real standard roller coasters I
suppose so I'm definitely going to
research that and also the goals on the
scenario
aren't too difficult we need to get 550
guests a happiness rating of 75 percent
and an experiences rating of 70 percent
I think the experiences rating is gonna
be a little bit more challenging but
other than that's nothing too much out
of the ordinary here
see yeah I'm just gonna try and build
some rides build some buildings and try
my first bobsled coaster of the
playthrough so far as well
so that should be interesting anyway
let's get started alright so I wanted to
start off here by the lakeside
because I didn't really know what to do
with the entrance area and I think
really whenever you feel like you want
to build somewhere in the middle of
nowhere just because you have the best
idea of what's a built there usually
it's a good idea to just go ahead and do
that and try to hook it up later at
least that's what I tried here because I
didn't really know what I wanted to do
with the entrance but I definitely
wanted to build some kind of small-town
feeling Bulevar next to the water over
here just because that interaction with
the lake I thought would be really neat
and I'm saying Lake but it's probably
the sea since these are islands and
that's also what my inspiration mostly
came from there's an archipelago just
off the coast of Gothenburg that I went
to last year which I think looks super
nice super charming lots of these little
villages with all these Swedish red
houses on them and that's what mostly
inspired me to go for the theme of this
map so yeah one ride over here and then
I'll just build some houses around that
put some of the necessary facilities in
and decorated all nicely and for some
reason I've been reading up on the
history of these houses in Sweden so if
you'll just allow me to go on a bit of
attentions basically I was wondering why
so many of the houses in Sweden were red
and I heard a long time ago that there
was something about red being a royal
collar of the king and people wanting to
go for that color for that reason turns
out that's not entirely what it's like
so basically in a town in Sweden called
Fallon I think there was a copper mine
which was such a huge and old copper
mine it operated for over a millennium
and it basically gave Sweden a monopoly
on the copper market the global one that
is for a really long time but one of the
byproducts of this copper was used for
red paints and as a result of that it
was super ubiquitous and people just
started using the red paints also partly
because historically it was used by
Swedish people to kind of emulates the
look of red brick houses in Europe so
it's more of a sort of aristocratic
thing but once this paint's became super
available to everybody everybody started
painting their house
and at that point the aristocracy I
think also decided to paint their houses
in different colors like white and
yellow but yeah that's basically why a
lot of houses in Sweden are red it just
kind of turned into a traditional thing
or because it was this one byproduct of
mining that they just had lying around
anyway and decided to turn into
something so I thought that was a really
interesting history and I'm definitely
gonna try and get as many red houses
into this build as well because it's
much of a cliche as it might seem if you
go to Sweden you really see red houses
and barns and sheds everything in red
everywhere so that's quite interesting I
think now I'm not making every single
building red it would be a bit boring
so here's just one unpainted wooden
house as well as a yellow one apparently
the advantage of painting them red as
well especially compared to not painting
your houses at all is that the paint's
does give some you know defensive
mechanisms to the wood so they don't
start to weather as quickly or rot as
quickly so that's probably definitely
part of the question as well it's a
theme that I really like for theme parks
though and maybe for similar reasons as
an American Western theme because it's
not too expensive to pull off it's not
too difficult it doesn't require a great
level of detail it's just a lot of wood
and very simple materials but it's
really charming and it's this really
nice sort of country style family owned
the theme park I guess counterparts to
the the western style of theme parks in
the US so when I was travelling across
Sweden I was actually on a road trip to
visit different theme parks and I've
noticed that a lot of these especially
family-owned theme parks in Sweden do
follow this very rustic Swedish style
for this Liseberg was a bit of an
example which has one main street with
really cool architecture along the sides
but even some of the smaller parks like
that one Park where it's run on is
skaara so Merlin's like there's this
really nice charming Swedish feeling to
a lot of the parks and even if it's not
super explicit it's just this this
really fun and charming atmosphere I
think so moving on to the entrance area
I really didn't have much of a clue of
what to do with this so you can probably
see that it turned out into a pretty
simple entrance area just trying to get
the bare bones of what I needed in here
as well as some wider paths in general I
try to always keep the paths a bit wider
at the entrance because this is where
most of the crowds are gonna be because
they haven't really dispersed into the
rest of the park yet and also you know
the the very necessary information kiosk
right at the start of the park this is
one of those quirks of rollercoaster
tycoon
that I guess I never really got over and
to be very frank I think a lot of what I
do in this game it just kind of comes
from my experience in roller coaster
[ __ ] sometimes in good ways I guess
because it has given me a lot of
experience with trying to dress up these
parks but also keeping an eye out for
finances and all of these little needs
tricks that I trying to use as much as
possible when it comes to theming and
stuff like that but in some ways it's
also helped me back I guess part of that
I guess is trying to place the
information kiosk at the start of the
scenario which I guess isn't too bad but
that's definitely a habit that I had
from roller coaster tycoon but in the
last video somebody also asked why I
never really build tunnels and that's
something that I always forget I didn't
really like doing that too much in
roller coaster tycoon because it's
really hard to get tunnels in there I
think that's one of the things that this
game greatly improves upon because you
really had to dig out a specific area
and get a vertical edge somewhere to
move your coaster into and you don't
need to do that in this game but sort of
from that experience I'm not very used
to putting stuff on the ground that and
also it's a bit broken if you do end up
putting stuff on the ground you can
completely Keys the scenarios and
to be very frank I've actually had some
conversations with the devs on this
because for some of the scenarios they
people tend to just make them a lot
easier by putting everything underground
when the space is limited so that's also
something to work out but yeah that's I
guess the twofold reason for one I'm not
really used to putting stuff on the
ground and I also think that you know
it's a bit more challenging if you try
not to build everything in the ground so
yeah that's basically that maybe I
should get up to speed a little bit here
so these two rights I figured it worked
quite well with this whole sort of hilly
area I really like it when you've got
these hilly areas with paths sort of
intertwining and these little planters
between them I tried to do that on
adventure Island as well but I think
over here it works out a little bit
better I don't know if it's the path
textures or just that they weave a
little bit better but I really like this
entrance area so far even though it's
very simple I think it gets the feeling
of these kinds of theme parks quite well
done I suppose so this is just about the
final parts of the entrance area I
really don't like putting rollercoasters
right next to the entrance I think at
this point I was kind of noticing a
trend here I actually tried the scenario
first building a bobsled ride at the
start right next to the entrance but
that didn't really work out and for me
the the entrance area of the park is
something I don't know supposed to more
just have buildings and flat rides and
kind of get you into the theme of the
park and then the rollercoasters for me
tend to be more towards the back which I
guess in an historical sense also kind
of works because a lot of parks will
start off as a more small park with just
flat rides and built their
rollercoasters only when they've
expanded a bit
speaking of rollercoasters it was that
it was finally time here to build a
bobsled coaster and what I think is
really interesting is that in this game
you can build both Mac and intamin
bobsleds so basically this is a mech
bobsled because it has a train but the
intamin bobsleds have like regular
typical traditional bobsled carriages
I guess which is this one car which can
see six people and those things are
incredibly rare the efteling is gonna
close their version later this year and
I think that was this the last or
second-to-last bobsled coaster from
intimate in the world which is kind of a
shame because I really like those I
honestly prefer them over the Mac
versions because even though these
things with the Train they're quite nice
they don't flow quite as well as the
traditional bobsled coasters I think
they just don't tend to go as much back
and forth they're also a little bit less
intense I've noticed in terms of their
drops and hills but they do have a lot
of advantages one of them being is that
they're still being built there are way
more of these in the world and there are
also more efficient I suppose maybe not
per se but if you build an intimate
bobsled you really have to put block
brakes everywhere or the thing is not
gonna work and with this bobsled usually
one or two mid-course brake runs should
do the trick so I decided to go for this
one instead I think it just fits a
little bit more into this Park but
hopefully one day I can build an
intimate one because I just really love
those things and I'm super sad that the
one in the efteling is disappearing even
though it's understandable because
intamin doesn't really support that
model anymore so I don't think they
supplied the parts for it anymore and
that basically makes it impossible to
have it in any of your parks without
ridiculous maintenance costs something
like that was the situation in any case
they are replacing it with two family
coasters which coming from the efteling
I guess that that's a good way to fill
out the roster of coaches that they have
but it's it's a bit disappointing to see
another family coaster in the efteling
anyway let's get back up to what I'm
doing here the layout is pretty much
finished here just built on top of this
hill um I didn't really know what to do
with the hill otherwise so it's just
gonna be this bobsled and I'll try to
have the rest of the park kind of go
around it and then for the station I was
thinking of building just one of these
red Swedish barns but in the end I
decided against that and I'm just
building a very generic
wooden station with this very kind of
standard wooden roof layouts which isn't
the best thing I suppose but it at least
looks a bit different than the other
buildings around it which i think is is
pretty good for a coaster station and
you at least wanted to stick out a bit
and make it clear that this is where the
coaster is and for once the queue line
entrance is actually even next to the
building and it's pretty visible so
that's probably one of my better queue
line placements even if it is quite a
short queue I think I'll be fine because
it's quite efficient there are three
trains on this thing
so even though it's one person for a car
it shouldn't be too inefficient and
finally here's a carousel because what's
a park without a carousel now let's see
how the park is doing and hopefully I
can actually make a profit out of this
so here's our little bobsled coaster and
surprisingly the park is actually making
a good amount of profits I really wasn't
expecting it to do this well but hey I'm
not complaining about that also somebody
suggested that I should turn off the UI
for these parts and I think that's a
pretty good idea so there you go so
altogether I think this ride works quite
well I'm pretty happy with the layout
actually it's really just two parts few
helixes here into a mid-course brake run
which is a thankfully well timed with
the lift so I didn't even put much
effort into that so I'm glad that it
actually works and then it's back into
the final brake run I'm actually gonna
probably put some catwalks
on these brake runs because I do think
they look a bit empty without them but
that's something to get into later for
now I'm really happy with how it turned
out and I'm also quite happy with how
the waterfronts over here turn out might
put a little bit more decoration in here
but altogether I think it pulls off the
simple rustic
atmosphere quite well and I think the
entrance area even if it's not too
complicated just a bunch of parts I
think it does a good job at just being
an entrance area
I still need to figure out what I'm
gonna do with this part of the park
because it's bit of a dead end
not quite sure what I can turn it into
but if we go over here there's a lot of
space there to work with and also I
think there we go I'm getting this steel
coaster that's really cool I don't think
yeah I don't have anything else yet but
I can definitely build something with
the steel coaster and don't want to
build a wild mouse think those work best
on flat terrain and since we have a
hilly scenario I think it'll be nice to
try and build something kind of terrain
conforming like the bobsled actually is
a little bit because it's based on top
of this hill basically I see yeah so far
so good and let's continue and see what
we can make of it so I'm still not too
sure what I want to do with the area
next to the entrance so instead I'm just
gonna keep on expanding into this part
of the park and like I always do when I
have no idea what to do I'm placing a
swinging ship over the water here which
always just works out really well
putting these things over beaches or
lakes just fits the theme really well
and even though I know that in real life
they don't really tend to be built like
this usually it's something that I
really like so I don't know if you've
noticed by now but I always tend to
place these things over some kind of
body of water anyway
aside from this there's just going to be
a small path way over here and not much
else because to be honest the bobsled is
just using a way too much space on this
part of the map and I think I also don't
want to fill in the whole map this is
one of those scenarios where you really
get this sort of lake in the middle of
your park even though technically this
is all just part of the sea the land
kind of is shaped around this this lake
in the middle of it so I really want to
build a park that is shaped very similar
to that shape and just kind of have a
part going around the lake and have all
the attractions right next to that but
not really expand into any other
territory I just think that works out
really well here and for this area I'm
actually trying a slightly different
theme which in hindsight for some of the
scenarios so far I wish I would have
done that a little bit more because so
far I'm really sticking to ones
in theme in every single scenario and I
think it might be fun to mix it up a
little bit as well and have some
slightly themed areas even though I'm
obviously not going to get the level of
Disney when it comes to scenery I still
like to add some themed lands here and
there so this I thought would be nice to
make into a sort of science fiction
research base something like that which
is a little bit more Arctic than most of
Sweden I have to admit but given the
theme I think it works pretty well I
think it looks quite neat and I've
always wanted to try one of these things
might as well incorporate it into the
theme of this park so this corner of the
park is just going to have this general
theme that said I'm not going to do too
much with it because this is quite a
small area and there's not a lot of
suitable land for flat rides and things
like that so at the moment it's just the
toilet building which is in the big
hangar style building and I still need
to stop myself from saying hunger that
just kind of feels much more natural to
me but yeah in that that small hangar
style building there's a toilets but
that's really about it everything else
is just setting the setting if you will
and creating this small setup of some
kind of scientific base so yeah quite
simple not too much to it but I think
it's nice to add an area of the game or
an area of the park which is slightly
different from the rest of the park that
is basically also it for this whole part
I don't think I'm adding anything but
scenery really in this part I was
thinking of placing a flat right down
somewhere and actually tried doing that
eventually as you'll see in a second but
I really kind of couldn't figure out how
to fit flat rides into the terrain
without having to make huge
modifications to it which on the other
hand I think is a huge plus on when it
comes to this scenario this is one of my
favourite scenarios to play so far
actually because it's a little bit more
challenging when it comes to terrain and
you really have to work your way around
all of these slopes the only real flat
area that you get is near the beginning
on that sort of
shelf which i guess is what the scenario
is named after probably but that aside
it's all just hills so that's a bit more
challenging but what I did decide I
needed it in this this area is some kind
of star attraction something to set this
land part and I figured a roller coaster
would be the West the best way to do
that and I just got the floorless
coaster through research which i think
is more fun coaster to build than the
steel coaster which I had before this so
I'm building a floorless coaster here
and for my inspiration I turned mostly
to Tivoli Gardens in Copenhagen Denmark
where they have a flawless coaster
called des moanin which i think is kind
of underrated it doesn't get as much
respect as other floorless coasters do
mostly because it's really small but
even though it's not the most thrilling
coaster I think it's absolutely
phenomenal when it comes to working with
the scenery around it and especially
working with a very limited space Tivoli
Gardens is a park which is in the middle
of Copenhagen right next to the Central
Station and really between the Central
Station and the city hall this is right
down in the middle of the city center
usually when you think about a theme
park which is inside the city it's not
exactly within the historic core of the
city but Tivoli Gardens is something
which goes back long into Copenhagen's
history which is really interesting but
because of that they are extremely tight
for space and day moanin is the most
compact coaster by bnm that I've ever
seen I don't think there's any bnm which
is more compact and that is and despite
that it has a really interesting layout
where it goes through a loop a dive loop
I think lots of twists and turns
above the pathways as well and a final 0
0 so this layout even though if you look
at it it looks quite a bit different it
does follow many of the similar elements
to des moanin and I'm trying to keep
this very tight and the idea is more or
less that you get this this coaster
which works quite well as a skyline to
see in the distance from
the rest of the park and from the lake
especially which i think is quite nice
having this on the hillside is very
compact but sort of stretched out
coaster works quite well and generally I
think that's just a nice sights to see
if you're somewhere in the rest of the
park even though I'm clicking an
isometric game this is still one of
those things that I like to keep in mind
when I'm building things so that's all
for the layouts and then for this
station I'm trying to get into the same
theme as I do for the rest of this area
and just go kind of sci-fi modern ish
wasn't quite sure to do of what to do
with this station so it's just a bit of
trial and error to get to a place where
I like it but it's just going to be
another simple rectangular station with
a gable roof on top of it but to add
some variation to it that there are some
like horizontal sides which are a little
bit lower and the middle parts of the
roof as you can see are tilting to both
sides so it's not a completely straight
simple roof there's a few details which
at least make it a little bit more
interesting than that I think and yeah
that is pretty much it for this area I D
I really wanted to add some flat rights
to this as well especially given how the
motion simulator and the cinema building
for the the cinema flat ride look really
sci-fi ish and would work quite well
with this theme of some kind of science
lab out in Scandinavia but in the end
there really isn't any space for it and
I don't want to start using the rest of
the island because I also still want to
get to the third island or a third land
within the park if you will where I want
to go for a slightly different theme
again so I don't want to dwell on this
area for too long and at this point I
was also running out of money I was
making money here again because I just
opened the coaster but I was kind of
confused for good while as to why I
wasn't making money anymore
where before I was and there really
wasn't anything wrong with the park I
didn't
vandalism or anything like that but I
just wasn't earning as much money as I
was before
that said I opened the floor list
coaster and right away I got hundreds in
profits every month again and for a
while to try and avoid that scenario
where I don't have any money to build
stuff anymore and after after placing
down every single tree I had to wait for
a bit until I had enough money to place
another one I'm just putting the game on
fast-forward to get a good amount of
money before I move on to building stuff
again and here again I'm also adding
some path covers or things that cover
the path that is underneath the track
which I need to do a little bit more
actually still but it's just something
that I always do out of safety reasons
and it helps to add a bit of scenery to
an area as well just works out and yeah
that is basically just about it for the
coaster the rest of this time-lapse is
just adding extra foliage and starting
to move on to the next area just to make
sure that this this whole land is going
to transition smoothly from the
different parts of the park as well but
altogether it doesn't feel too out of
place I was really afraid that this area
would feel too radically different from
the rest of the park but I think as long
as you're generally using the same
foliage and some similar path elements
things like that it can still work quite
well
really the only real important thing is
to transition somehow from one land to
another and I think having that small
parts with a pirate ship where there
really isn't anything else in terms of
scenery transitions well enough from
this area to the next one and then over
here I'm building a bridge as the next
transition which I think works quite
well as well I'll still have to see what
I'm gonna do with the next Island
to be honest I'm thinking about doing
some kind of more Renaissance style
Swedish architecture so working more
with stone and making it look a little
bit more like architecture that you
would see in the middle of a city of
Stockholm but I still need to figure out
how exactly I'm going to
that anyway that's it for this
time-lapse so let's see how the pike is
doing well then here we are and the
coaster is making more profits than I
know what to do with and it honestly is
running pretty well and I haven't even
checked out the stats too much yet but
extreme excitement rating versus a
medium intensity and low nausea it's
pretty good and the decorations that is
actually already amazing I didn't expect
it to be amazing yet but I guess the
trees possibly helped quite a bit with
that and the station is made up of a lot
of pieces and really the only thing that
the game's checks I think to check for
decoration stats is the amount of
different scenery pieces that you're
using so that's all quite good and I
think it has a decent speed as well in
terms of making it through all of the
elements so yeah I'm really happy with
this and really it does feel very
similar to the moanin in terms of what
elements it's doing with the vertical
loop and the dive loop and the Immelman
as well and there's two helixes which is
very similar as well and ending with a
zero zero everything is just in a kind
of slightly different place and there's
an extra a moment I believe if I can
remember the layouts for daemon and well
enough but yeah definitely feels like
its own layouts just inspired by so I'm
pretty happy with this ride I'm also
really happy with the bobsled and I
think I showed off the stats for that
one but this one works really well as
well I wasn't expecting the bobsled to
get stats that were this good but an
excitement rating of 70 is really good
so I'm asking $12 for this one could
possibly ask for more money but it's
working so far and for the floorless
coaster I'm asking for $15 to answer it
which is very steep but hey there the
guests are willing to pay this so might
as well and then the next step is to
expand into this part of the park and
maybe hopefully one day actually do
something with this area which is
currently just a dead end
I think I won't be able to really do
much with it it's just going to be a
flat ride or two yeah maybe just one
flat ride but we do need this area to
you get the staff to go to the the staff
building thingamajig here actually has a
God speaking of that I forgot to place
down a staff room in a training room
okay I'm gonna have to do that as soon
as possible I should actually probably
do that down here somewhere that's
something I need to fix I always forget
about those things but that aside I
think the pike is running quite fine
there enough toilets and shops and stuff
like that for everyone to be quite happy
and all of the guests do seem to be
pretty happy and in fact I'm pretty well
on my way to reaching the goal because
the happiness and experience is rating
is pretty good I just need to get 550
guests and if my estimate is correct
just one more coaster and maybe a few
more flat rides should be able to get us
to 550 guests so let's get building
again all right so what I decided to
build is something inspired by some of
the islands that you find in Stockholm
which is a city that I visited last
summer and I really liked the
interaction that the city has with the
water there's lots of these islands and
just waterfront areas which are
absolutely beautiful but on our way from
the city center to a park called groan
Island
I probably terribly mispronounced that
but I really suck at Swedish
pronunciation so I'm sorry about that
but yeah on our way to that park we had
to catch a ferry and this ferry also
passes by some islands with some old I
believe we've sort of castles and
previously used military barracks or
things like that in any case some
islands with some architecture on it
that looks really cool and I was mostly
inspired by that to build this so it's a
little bit more urban and dense than
some of the other parts of the park but
I was also inspired by just the overall
skyline that the area of growing island
has because as you're approaching that
park it's on the water as well so the
ferry is right next to it and you just
see these towers of the drop towers and
the buildings and the roller coasters
all in this super tight spot and it just
looks really cool the view from there is
absolutely amazing so that was the the
general
our idea that I had when I wanted to get
into this part of the park
now obviously space is really limited
here so the only coaster type that I
could you know feasibly figure out a way
to feature into the scenery was the I
think this is the other steal the wild
mouse coaster which is not my favorite
coaster I'm not a big fan of how it
looks and it doesn't interact with
scenery all that well but it's really
compact and it has lots of straight
pieces and I wanted to build something
which would go in and out of buildings a
lot and interact as much as possible
with the scenery of the island also
please ignore the Trop tower that I'm
just building right now I completely
forgot that I was already that I already
built a drop tower in the park before
and I'm not even sure how I didn't
notice it because I I went back to check
whether I already I already built this
drop tower and for some reason I didn't
notice the the previous one it just kind
of it was invisible to me for some
reason so I built another drop tower and
I'll be going back to the other area of
the park to remove the old one and try
to come up with another way to use that
space because I don't want to have the
same exact ride twice although Corona
learned has a lot of drop towers some of
them really good it has I think it has a
drop tower which is just pretty much a
regular old launched drop tower it has
one drop tower which is really unique
and it tells you forward or really it
tilts you downward 90 degrees before it
lets you drop so you you just look
straight at the ground where you're
dropping from that one and by the time
that you get down to the ground the the
seats kind of swing out into the side so
you don't get stupid high g-forces into
the harnesses but yeah that's an amazing
ride definitely one of my favorite drop
towers that I've ever been on if not my
favorite and then it also has a star
flyer which isn't quite a drop tower but
it sort of adds to the aesthetic of the
park of just picking a cluster of these
different tower rides I don't think I
forgot any there you mostly just see
three
of the park I think but yeah that that's
the sort of aesthetic of the park and
that's what really makes it draw your
attention when you're in the rest of the
city because you can see the park from
quite a distance just because you see
these towers so yeah I thought that was
really cool
wanted to do this on this island I just
forgot that I already had a drop tower
in the park so I'm gonna figure that out
later so for the rest of the scenery I
mostly built the layout of the coaster
with an idea of scenery in mind as you
might be able to tell because the layout
is really weird
I just based the layouts on how I wanted
the buildings to be and how I wanted the
layout to sort of weave in and out of
these buildings so it's a very simple
general shape I would say just one
interior Plaza with a bunch of buildings
around it sort of castle like in a sense
that lots of the buildings have slightly
different colors and textures but they
all form a single coherent wall around
this this middle Square which is a I
guess something typical of castles
because they tend to be built across
different ages so everything's a little
bit different but hopefully it should
all come together to form one nice
building and I hope that's not going to
fill I also like the tower here just
because for me every big building needs
at least one spire or dome or something
that's taller than the rest of the
building that sort of draws your
attention and I think putting this tower
on the top of the lift Hill is a a
pretty cliched and tried-and-true method
of integrating coasters into scenery for
me Black Mamba in Fantasyland comes to
mind but it works really well so I just
wanted to put that out there and just to
just to keep the whole Swedish theme
because in the end I'm still trying to
base this as much as possible on Swedish
architecture there's a little red
Swedish house in here as well but all of
the colors and the textures of the rest
of the buildings are loosely based on
what you see in the city centre of
Stockholm see how that's that's
basically what inspired me I also had to
research
scenery at this point I believe because
I didn't start out with the brick walls
but I really wanted to use those because
you might be able to tell that the
buildings that I've built so far are
just made out of regular old plaster
which isn't too bad but they're kind of
builds to be brick buildings so for some
of the other buildings I do want to get
into that so add some research and some
scenery at this point it's not too big
of an issue because I'm already earning
way more money than I even know what to
do with so I honestly just poured a
thousand dollars into research every
month at this point which ends up going
really quickly I think just in general
research is something which is quite
crucial in the earlier stages of the
scenarios and really something that you
have to carefully balance out your
budget for but as soon as you start
making some good profits you know the
research costs don't scale up with the
growth of the rest of the park so it
just gets easier and easier to get
research the further you are into the
scenario which is making it a little bit
more easy to get into more different
rides and scenery types the later into
the scenario you get I'm not even sure
if this is a criticism or just an
overall you know a positive thing for me
it's just something that I've noticed
and something to keep in mind and I
suppose anyway moving on we've got the
station not too spectacular here all of
these buildings on their own are just
really simple I'm trying to just make
sure that all together they work well
but really the building's themselves I'm
not detailing or making too spectacular
they really just come out they're
supposed to fit into the bigger picture
I suppose and finally here's a small
entrance building for the queue because
I keep messing up on the cues and not
making them stand out you know but with
this I think this is a decent entrance
to the queue although maybe I should
have put a sign out front not entirely
sure maybe in real life that would be a
thing but given that this is pocket X
and you automatically get these sort of
signs on the queue paths that sign
doesn't work as well with
building walls so I decided to have the
Q sub start inside the building instead
of having the sign right out front not
too sure how much I like that but I
think looking at the building it works a
little bit better and then there's a
little bit more detailing and some of
the awnings and things like that I
didn't actually talk about the drop
tower itself but one of the reasons why
I decided to keep this drop tower rather
than the one that's in the other parts
of the park is because I did add some
decorations to this which is something
which i think is very fun and something
which you can always just try just to
put some roof pieces and decoration
pieces on top of your drop towers or
observation towers or things like that
it's a pretty easy way to incorporate
them into a theme and to dress them up a
little bit more and it's something which
happens in real life as well
I remember that most recently Hansa Park
has revealed their newest drop Tower
which has this sort of castle elements
on top of the drop tower I'm not sure
how much of a fan I am of it it looks a
little bit cheap to be honest and I
definitely think they could have built
something better if maybe they had more
budget allocation or whatever but the
idea of you know putting extra scenery
on top of rides I think is really fun
and there aren't any clearance issues in
this game like in rollercoaster tycoon
and you could never do this because it
wouldn't allow you to put scenery on top
of rides but as long as the clearance is
fine really I think it's it's fun way to
add your own flair to flat rides so yeah
that is basically all of the buildings
and really most of the scenery of the
island at this point I was recording in
the middle of the night and I really
wanted to go to sleep so I went back to
next day to continue adding some more
decorations I really kept the middle
square empty because I wasn't sure what
to do with it and I ended up just
filling it with a small interior garden
it's not the best thing in the world but
I think it works better than just having
parts there just having the foliage in
the center is
quite nice I think it's a bit of a
French garden touch I suppose and I'm
not sure how Scandinavian it is but
given that so many European countries
have sort of imitated these French style
symmetric gardens I think it works quite
alright oh and then there's the tower
which is there for a little other reason
than just to provide a little arch for
the coaster to go through because I had
choppers hat choppers are always fun and
I think in real life this this ride
would be full of them I also need to
give a shout out to a ride called
gazenga zoo which I also probably
butchered the name of but it's a it's a
girl our bobsled coaster in a park
called trips trail which is a park that
I've talked about before in some of my
videos and I think actually I was sort
of inspired by it on my first episode of
park attacks but I can't remember
exactly anymore but yeah it's it's a
very charming Park in southern Germany
looks really cool and the bobsled
coaster which can be a bit confusing but
a girl our bobsled coaster like the
Sanctus hour isn't a traditional bobsled
as in one that swings on a big track but
rather it sits like a wild mouse with
banked curves and just more advanced
elements in general but yeah that that
ride I think is really amazing because
it has some really cool interaction with
scenery there is a castle around that
area which is where the coaster kind of
goes through its and interacts with it
and I just think that that whole
concepts of using a bobsled coaster to
get some sort of scenery interaction
with the coaster is quite nice because
these coasters have lots of different
parts they'll have the sections where
there are airtime Hills
they'll have sections where they're
focused on these hairpin turns that wild
Mouse's are famous for and there are
sections with curves and they all kind
of lent themselves to different kinds of
scenery so yeah I was sort of inspired
by that ride also to build my world
mouse coaster here anyway moving on to
the start of the park which I still
hadn't finished at this point I decided
to remove the drop tower
and put my faith into research because I
didn't have a drop tower to replace it
with and I just clicked some research in
hopes of getting another drop tower and
I did which is pretty awesome and better
yet this is the exact drop tower that
they have ingrown eluned so this is the
one that tilts you 90 degrees and then
you fly face down down to the ground
which is absolutely amazing these things
are really fun even though the one
ingrown Eluned isn't that tall it's
really much more thrilling than taller
drop rides I think just because you're
looking straight down and not just
because you're looking straight down for
me also it really helps the experience
is to know that you're only held there
by the restraints sitting in a seat
definitely feels a little bit more safe
than just being held back from certain
death by a little restraint that's over
your shoulders so yeah great ride and I
decided to finish up the park with a
chair swing because I didn't have that
yet I definitely checked to make sure I
didn't have two chair swings and it just
rounds up the roster of rides in the
park quite well and yeah that is
basically it's for this park so let's
take one last look at it and see how it
looks all right so here's the final land
of the park which I really wasn't too
sure about in the beginning but in the
end I really liked it the most out of
any part of the park so yeah really
happy with this I think the ride isn't
that great but given that it is a wild
mouse ride which is pretty difficult to
incorporate into scenery like this I
think it works out quite well and even
the stats on it aren't too bad either so
the rest of this island is really just
quite simple we've got the drop tower
and a ferris wheel but really the main
focus is on all of the scenery here and
then this sort of sci-fi land with this
sort of research facilities and stuff
like that I think work well with the
theme of the coaster as well this is
something that I haven't really pointed
out so far but I really feel like
certain coasters tend to work better
with certain kinds of themes and this
coaster being kind of high-tech like a
florida's B&M coaster
I think that just works really well with
the sci-fi theme I wouldn't be putting a
wooden coaster in a sci-fi theme any
time soon for instance see I like this
area as well and then we've got the
starting area with the more sort of
traditional Swedish look to it with all
of these red houses which I think work
out quite well in the end as well so
yeah all together I'm quite happy with
the park although I do have to say the
frame rates has dropped a little bit
more than the scenarios so far I can
definitely notice it by the end it's of
course a little bit worse since I got
way more guests in the park since the
guests goal is higher and also I'm
recording right now but still it's
something that I noticed as well and
I'll just point it out here I'll try not
to come back to it in the future too
much but while it's not been much of an
issue on building stuff especially when
you're just zoomed in on a particular
area it's it's noticeable when you're
zoomed out when the park is all finished
and all the guests are walking around
but yeah as a general conclusion I don't
want to leave it there I'm really quite
happy with this park it's not my
favorite so far but I actually really
like the scenario itself I really wasn't
expecting to like it this much of course
I've played it before but just in
general I never really took it to the
final objective I only sort of messed
around in this starting area but
building in the whole park kind of made
me realize how well this map works you
know it's just another map that with a
little bit of effort you can fill in the
whole map in but it's not like you leave
anything out it's not like you have to
go out of your way to fill any spaces up
and you also don't really run out of
space so I think it's good for a sort of
intermediate scenario and having these
sort of cold climates is a nice change
from all of the tropical vibes that we
get in the other scenarios in this part
of the game so yeah all together I'm
happy with this and I'm gonna miss out
on the animation for getting the trophy
because I already went to that off the
camera but we got this little house
which is from the entrance area
I believe and the next scenario is
Biscayne Beach over here we already had
that but then there's happy ko Harbor on
this side which I've heard is pretty
difficult but then again so is Biscayne
Beach anyway that's it for now thanks
for watching guys and I'll see you in
Batavia kay